so before we kick off and we talk about
building data pipelines a few words
about me my name is Marco nice to meet
you
my background is software engineering
I've been a developer for seven or eight
years before kind of going back to
school and getting my PhD in information
retrieval
so today I like to build such
applications and in general natural
language processing applications and
they tried to kind of merge the best of
both side the engineering and the
research side in terms of stuff I'm
working on right now I'm wrapping up my
first book on data mining for social
media in Python so should be relevant
for the PI data crowd and it will be out
over the summer so the starting point of
this talk I have to say initially when I
was writing the proposal I was thinking
about an introduction to Luigi which is
one of the tools I'm going to mention
but then it took a step back kind of
trying to look at the bigger picture
things got a bit on the philosophical
side so the starting point is Randy is
not engineering and I think we can we
can all agree on on this so of course in
well I'm using R&D as a kind of a
catch-all terms for academic research
apply the research data science and data
science is stuff I just want to check
with you how many in the audience are
software engineers
software developers whew yeah and who is
on the R&D or academic research side ok
so this isn't split my point is the good
results of R&D when they go in
production they are definitely high
value so how can we either the
transition from R&D to production a
little bit of wisdom from from Twitter
if we apply the 80/20 rule to our
industry 80% of the time spent cleaning
data and
the remaining 20% complaining about the
need of preparing data it's not far from
from reality and the take-home message
from this is really you know I've been
I've been talking to a lot of people in
the industry and whether they have big
data or not doesn't really matter
because they all have big problems with
data so what I'm trying to say here is a
data preparation data cleaning that are
quality data governance whatever you
call it is really still a very important
a very important point here so it's
where most of your effort are going to
be spent now if we take a traditional
database a textbook and we look at at
the data warehousing terminology we find
ETL as a as a classic way to represent
basically everything that happens before
we can do our smart analytics so ETL for
extract transform and load is never so
simple so it's never so linear usually
we have many many components in the ETL
Saida we need to extract data from many
Terrigen sources we need to clean data
deduplication missing values all the
sort of problems then we might want to
apply some data augmentation data
tagging whatever you call it and then
join at the end multiple data sets so
potentially the ETL box in the in the
middle can get really complicated and
this everything that happens before we
can run our machine learning application
or data analytics in a broader sense if
we build the data pipelines we might as
well be the good data pipeline and my
opinion there are there are two key
points to keep in mind so a good data
pipeline is something that is easy to
replicate so we can share it with
colleagues and we can replicate
experiments so replicability in science
generally speaking is a good idea and
also a good data Python is something
that is easy to bring to production so
is it to productize so the question is
how can we do that
so moving keeping this in mind
replicability and easy to productize if
we move towards good data pipelines what
do we need to do a few a few and real
photo real life experiences data
transformation keep your data as a
suggestion don't overwrite your data you
should always be able to rerun the
pipeline from the beginning that's about
data SONET in general but more
specifically specifically about your own
sanity when you try to replicate
experiments if we follow design of
Python you know simple is better than
then complex it's better to start simple
and add complexity later in particular
at some point we're going to need to
break down the pipeline into individual
components and if we're talking about
Python we can break it down into
individual packages so applying you know
the set up I set up to is kind of
library and rather than having a big
data pipeline break it into smaller
components and one more suggestion as
soon as possible try to get an
end-to-end test of your pipeline so the
components of your pipeline should
should work well in isolation but they
should work well as a pipeline so
end-to-end tests as soon as possible
will we kind of give you we can trace
the problems if they are there you
shouldn't forget about testing the
components in isolation anyway so unit
testing is still very important now as a
the process of building pipelines have
seen master students business
students and even more more senior
people going through the same kind of a
pattern and the same kind of mistakes so
you start with a script and then you hug
something together and then you have a
bunch of scripts that individually that
don't really make sense so what they
call a script soup and then in order to
try to make some some sense of this big
soup you may be right kind of a master
script to run everything and what you
end up with is really a sort of a hockey
homemade solution where you rana in the
wheel and things are still flaky and
difficult to share and difficult to
rerun so what we mentioned before about
replicability and going to production is
really not there yet in terms of don't
reinventing the wheel there are many
tools out there to manage pipelines
complex pipelines and I'm going to
mention one in a moment before going
there I just want to talk a bit more
about testing so another question for
you who is how many of you are everyday
writing unit tests exactly so this round
is for you
so testing in the broader sense and unit
tests in particular generally speaking
people think unit testing is a good idea
but they don't put it in practice and
unit testing in Python is quite simple
you have the unit test package part of
the standard library then you write your
test and then you quit complaining about
the lack of time to write tests and the
last step is really optional as long as
you do step one and step two
to answer your question unit test is a
test right you write a test for the
smallest component so you test the
smallest assumption and you want to
validate the smallest assumption so the
benefits of unit testing basically you
create a safety net because every time
you touch something in your code you're
risking a big problems basically you're
gonna break something as you touch
something you break something nice and
your unit tests if you write a decent
set of tests are protecting you from
these kind of mistakes and it's
particularly useful to have a good set
of tests say on a Friday afternoon when
you need to touch something and you
don't want to stay late in the office we
can look at unit tests then as a way to
validate your assumptions you have your
your code your functions so you think in
terms of input and expected output right
so you validate your assumption data
types and so on and you can look at the
unit test also as a way to communicate
your intention so if your if your code
if your piece of code is a black box
input and output you write down your
expectations in terms of unit test
unit tests are also useful in terms of
software design so if something is
difficult to test probably you can
refactor it and make it cleaner so
that's what I mean when you say it's you
you're forced to think so you're first
to think about what you expect input and
output again
if you are on the academic side and you
say I don't write a production code so I
don't really need to write any any unit
tests say you're writing a paper you
write your analysis and you end up with
some numbers these are taken from from a
real paper do you see the problem
precision and recall common in in
machine learning and then you calculate
the F score which is the harmonic mean
or precision recall so you expect the
number to be in between precision recall
so this out of bound and I've seen this
in a paper published in a plastic on
France so how we can how can we work
around this problem if we are in the
process of writing some analysis and we
need to test our numbers it's really one
line of Python so you calculate your
your F score your precision recall
somewhere then you sort out which one is
the lower bound and the upper bound and
then the third line here is an assertion
where you validate your assumption so
the Assumption here is that the F score
is somewhere in between the other two
numbers so the unit test is just testing
the smallest of the assumption we don't
know if the precision and recall values
are correct we don't know if the F score
is correct we just want to check whether
EF score is between precision and recall
if you never seen a unit test before
this piece of code alone is not a unit
test you still need to write the
boilerplate code so test case class and
and your function but that's pretty much
it in terms of logic also you should use
the assertion from the unit test package
that I mentioned earlier but it looks
pretty much like a unit test so the the
message here is a writing a single unit
test is really really really simple you
test a simple assumption
and you want to test the smallest
possible unit you don't want to to have
a big of the bigger picture in a unit
test okay so I'm nearly done with the
with the discussion on the unit tester
some suggestions if you are just
starting with unit testing so the
approach of loading some assertion in
your code rather than I'm right in the
unit test is cause sometimes defensive
programming I'm not particularly a great
fan of defensive programming but if you
don't need to write production code so
you just write a script and you're the
only user of that script that's one way
to do it so you don't need the unit test
package you just put assertions here and
there and if the condition is not valid
the assertion will blow up and raise an
assertion error so it's one way to check
your assumptions are correct
I prefer unit testing coming from from a
product oriented point of view but the
fancy programming is also one option if
you put some effort in writing tester
you should avoid a couple of things in
particular tautologies so tautology says
when you repeat yourself so you write
something that doesn't add any extra
value for example if you write your
logic in the unit test and the test is
wrong you don't know if if the bug is in
the test or in the original function so
you should really treat your code as a
black box input/output expectation not
anymore you shouldn't write any logic in
the unit test and then 180 testing is is
what happens when you start buying into
unit tests you think it's a good idea
you like it you start writing unit tests
for everything and you don't add any
value right so unit that should be
useful should tell you something if you
don't just write tests for the sake of
it in particular this concept of
coverage which is the proportion of
lines that are touched by any unit test
you shouldn't use coverage to to say
look I have a high cover so
my unit test is sorry my code is well
tested you should kind of think the
other way around
use coverage tools to highlight which
portion of the code is not tested yet
and this discussion about coverage also
goes into knowing the ecosystem so we
have unit tests as part of the standard
library and then we have a whole bunch
of useful libraries for testing we have
eye test and nose that kind of collects
your tests and allow you to run tests in
different way we have coverage dot pi
for the co graduate you also have a nice
GUI that I'll eyes what what you have
testing and and what you haven't you
know green line green tasted red line
doesn't and then we have hypothesis
which is a library to define strategies
for your tests so you can really kind of
brute force your your unit test you
define what kind of input you want and
then the library will produce any sort
of random rubbish that could potentially
go through your function and it will
help you to highlight the edge cases
that you didn't think about okay so I
ran out of Kota in terms of ranting and
I carry on with the work from managers
that I mentioned earlier so I want to
introduce Luigi which is a Python
library it belongs to the family of work
from managers if you are familiar with
UNIX you can think of it as a make files
plus unique UNIX pipes plus antennas in
terms of features what you do with Luigi
you define the dependencies between your
tasks so you have a pipeline made by
many component each component depends on
something else and you can define this
in Luigi by writing a very little Python
code and you have some sort of error
control and fare failure recovery out of
the box one nice features of luigi is
the visualization of this dependency
graph
one of the key concepts in Luigi is the
task so Luigi task is a just a task
nothing more a unit of execution and
what you see here is all the code you
need to write in order to define your
task so you define your task as a class
which standard the Luigi task and then
you need to define three methods first
one requires you just write down the
list of dependencies so what this task
is depending on then you define your
output this will be maybe a file or a
piece of data in the database and then
finally the business logic of your task
is define in the run method if you broke
down the pipeline into packages and you
have your own libraries so what you
write here basically is just your
library dot run or your library dot main
whatever you call it
so really the the extra code that you
need to write to get the dependency
controlled is really small another core
concept of Luigi is the target which is
the output of a task a target either
exists or not so the only function that
you need to define here is exists and it
will return true or false nice thing
about Luigi and the kind of the
ecosystem the community is that people
have written already a lot of targets
for many many different types of data so
Amazon s3 elasticsearch
many many database systems you can find
everything in the widget country package
so this coming kind of out of the box if
you have a you know a new exotic
database system that is not it does not
really support Yetta you just need to
write that kind of class so I mentioned
ouija because I had some positive
experience with Luigi but I'm not trying
to sell you Luigi what I'm trying to
sell you is the concept of workflow
managers and there are many options
today particular airflow mister job and
pin
these are all Python base libraries so
when I chose Luigi at the time all these
were far behind in terms of feature in
terms of community support
so Luigi was a bit more mature a bit
more complete I think nowadays they're
pretty much on the same level what I
like about Luigi is that the extra
effort in terms of a Python code that
you need is really really minimal ok
another concept that is often neglected
when when we write a academic code that
has to go in production is the concept
of logging a few weeks back there was
Alex metallic giving a keynote at PyCon
Italy and he said the login library is
something that scares people off because
storage the problem here is a yeah it's
true that you can do a lot of stuff with
with login but you can start with with
the basics really so it's not difficult
to start with so import login part of
the standard library again why is it
better than just printing for debugging
because you can customize everything so
you can customize your log format and
you have extensive information already
available in the login for example what
kind of which line is causing the
problem what kind of severity you want
to highlight so you want info you want a
debug you want to errors different
levels of information that you want to
log and once you slot your login
functions in your code it's very easy to
switch it off and it's very easy to
decide what you want to see I'm only
want to hide on the other side if you go
through the classic print function for
debugging then you have to go back and
either remove it or touch your code
again and again instead logging is kind
of a production already and then you can
decide whether you want to see your logs
on the screen or you want to save it on
some file and so on
so login you run your pipeline overnight
go to the office in the morning first
thing you do is not reading the logs
right so you need some sort of a
mechanism some sort of trigger that will
tell you something goes wrong in
particular with Luigi you have an email
notification system already out of the
box so you can get an email with the
last trace back if you have an exception
run happening in your code or you can
also use one of the many integrations in
particular I'm working on Luigi slack
integration is a work in progress that
is basically pushing a message on on
your slug channel or on a private as a
private message and you can get a some
sort of report about the pipeline
execution now in summary starting point
was R&D is not engineering and the
question is can we meet halfway my
answer is yes usually I don't like when
companies build a huge wall between the
R&D team and the production engineering
team I prefer to kind of sit in the
middle and and bring the two teams
together and one way to do that is learn
some basic engineering principles I
mentioned testing I mention login I
mentioned the way of packaging and
refactoring things and these are really
basics that you can you can benefit from
even if you stay on the academic side so
even if you don't have to go to
production if you think in term of terms
of production still you can benefit from
it and your code overall will will
improve and will give you better chances
of working on what you like basically so
you spend less time debugging more time
doing analysis I mention replicability
as something important in science and of
course in engineering as well automation
everything that can be automated
probably should be automated because
otherwise you get bored and when you get
bored is when you make mistakes right so
using the tools out there that are
already well prepared and feature-rich
for example Luigi but any of the work
from manager is going to be helpful and
before closing I just want to mention
the slicin on the speaker deck the
widgets lock component is in my github
and the great everything was on the
slack channel also I'm fairly easy to
find and if you want to reach out that's
quite easy I think that's all for me any
question sorry I didn't get that
yes the question is about not using a
printer and using the login package I
use login in Python 3 I use nearly for
every project only Python 3 the point is
a printer is much less flexible than
logging why would you want to redefine
it if it's already there so the login is
as much more flexible in terms of
changing the configuration after you
slot in all your login information we
print you don't have the same kind of
flexibility so I've write my login once
and then I only change one line at the
beginning of the file to change the
configuration that's all you need to do
if you want to switch it off
redirect somewhere change the severity
and so on the print print is not
flexible that does the short answer
yeah that's that's not easy you can use
assertions so it depends on what you do
with your jib so Jupiter notebooks okay
we're not we're not using the lift
so yeah the suggestion if it depends on
what you're using your notebooks for and
probably defensive programming in this
case is more useful so you use lot in
assertions rather than right in the the
proper unit tests here and then as you
execute your notebook err if something
is wrong you will see
assertions yeah you simply you you you
test a particular condition so an
engineer can easily read an assertion
and translate it into a unit test
usually you don't write assertions as I
did in production code because first of
all if you ran Python in non debug mode
which is what you should do in
production assertions are silenced and
secondly because you don't want your
code to just blow randomly in production
you want to test it on the side so I
think the fancy program is a place in
the ecosystem I don't particularly like
it when I build products but I think in
notebooks they make sense in general in
terms of scalability of Luigi they
recommend to use it up to maybe tens of
thousands of jobs per day no more it's
oriented to batch processing so if you
need something more real time and in the
millions of jobs kind of scalar probably
you should look into something like
salary and you're going to be a lot more
involved only on the dev up side so
salary just to mention is a is a job
queue basically so you need sort of
back-end some sort of message broker and
that you know it's beyond R&D usually
there's a lot of DevOps involved so I
guess tens of thousands of jobs is still
fine you can specify how many workers
you want in a in a single machine it's a
pure Python what you run doesn't have to
be Python so you can call us something
external and Luigi will will just be the
glue around your pipeline
so how does the dependency tree work so
it's a dagger directed graph you define
it in your coda
when you write your task and Luigi will
read your code when you run Luigi you're
saying I want this task to be run so the
end of the pipeline and then Luigi will
kind of read the dag backwards and we
try to see what kind of task you've run
already and what you didn't and static
okay so you define your drop your graph
at the beginning and then you run Luigi
you don't you don't have a dynamic
aspect of it so that's again salaries
probably better tool for this job if you
have new jobs coming dynamically and you
want to throw them in in your pipeline
so yeah with Luigi you define a dog and
with most of our workflow managers that
I mentioned you just define your dog at
the beginning in the back
so end-to-end testing so n2n testing you
need to do something right so you should
test your components in in isolation so
run your component with real data in
isolation so I'm not talking unit tests
and talking end-to-end tests for the
individual component and then you can
either test your end-to-end pipeline
with Luigi or kind of triggering the
individual tasks manually I think it
doesn't really matter as long as as you
as you do something about it you don't
have to kind of test Luigi you have to
run VG and test your code so that
there's a subtle difference here
so test your expectations with Luigi but
on test Luigi person yeah one more in
the back
so the one work for managers support in
terms of other languages the ones I
mentioned are pure Python but you can
call external tools so you can have a
say Java Scala application and you call
the JVM from Python or you can call any
UNIX command-line kind of tool or
whatever you like so the Python code
that you write is just the definition of
your pipeline and how the individual
components work or if there is a
database in the middle or elasticsearch
or whatever that's fine from the widgets
point of view and also from the other
work for managers it's kind of a like
I'm writing make files you know some
sort of sense so the question is whether
you can trigger the pipeline from Luigi
short answer no and the question kind of
comes up more and more so probably snow
so obvious when I first was looking into
Luigi for me it was quite clear the
separation of defining the pipeline that
is what you do in Luigi and running the
pipeline and I've seen this as plain as
maybe a shortcoming of Luigi what you
have to do is you have three options
either you run the pipeline manually or
you use a cron job to schedule the the
pipeline or you integrate your pipeline
with say Jenkins or any other CI - so in
this way you can also inject some
environment information into the
pipeline so no there is no mechanism
built-in in Luigi to run the pipeline
with some sort of a crown or so you need
to use external tools
yes yes so real-life examples of Luigi
I'm working mainly in NLP so in NLP you
have more or less a bunch of
pre-processing steps that you always
want to do or at least you want to try
so tokenization stemming stop or removal
the entity extraction the user things
and sometimes you don't know which one
works best for your for your data set
and that's that's one one of the
examples
another example is right now I'm working
in recruitment data so matching
candidate profiles with job
specification with some machine learning
and then we have data cleaning duplicate
profiles profiles that are not really
well defined so we want to augment with
with the additional labels and all these
all these types are applied to different
data sets so we have a few steps in
parallel and then we can emerge
everything and this you know naturally
it looks like a dog so we define it with
Luigi it's quite straightforward but
really because the the extra code that
you need to write with Luigi is so small
it makes sense to use it every time you
need to to do some pre-processing step
yeah so the question is about the entry
barrier to luige I think personally I'm
very comfortable with eunuchs so I like
make files and all the weird things but
I've spoken to people in biology
chemistry so they are domain expert in
whatever they are studying and but they
are not software engineers so they don't
want to bother and Luigi is nice because
you don't write that much code so the
concept is quite simple you you write a
dag and the extra colder
Speight on so probably you are already
familiar with Python and there's really
not much work to do if you if your
pipeline is a two-step certain maybe you
don't need a workflow manager but you
know from from three steps up it is nice
and you have a you have a bunch of
features out of the box like error
control and rerun in the pipeline if
something breaks
halfway through you rerun it not from
the beginning but from the last point of
failure so I I definitely recommend a
work from manager in general and as I
said I mentioned widget because I might
be with with Luigi from the back yeah
suitable to its oriented to batch
processing so it really depends if batch
processing is is what you need then you
can use Luigi if you need something more
real time then work from managers in
general are not what you need you
probably need to be a bit more involved
on the message passing around so that's
that's my short answer on that yeah I
think we we ran out of time I can take
the next few questions during the coffee
break I'm here all weekend and you can
find me at a meet-up as well thank you